damalige juso vize olaf scholz war auf
dem osten hier 1987 bei einem
friedensmarsch in wittenberg seite an
seite mit dem fdj chef eberhard aurich
hier unten in der hocke zu sehen im
vergleich zu anderen einreisenden genoss
scholz vorzüge die sonst keiner hatte
wenn olaf scholz in der ddr ein reiste
wurde er bevorzugt behandelt es gab
direkte anweisungen an die grenze dass
ein visum kostenfrei erteilt wurde dass
er kein mindest umtausch leisten musste
dass man ihn höflich behandelte und
teilweise musste er noch nicht mehr eine
zollkontrolle über sich ergehen lassen
aber wie gelangte der mittzwanziger mit
lockenkopf aus hamburg ins visier der
stasi und wieso diese vorzugsbehandlung
schon als gymnasiast in den 70er jahren
trat scholz den jusos bei in den
blickwinkel der sed regierung rückte er
vor allem weil er 1982 mehrfach gegen
brd kanzler helmut schmidt und die nato
wetterte außerdem gehörte er zu dieser
zeit auch dem stammlokal flügel an einer
marxistischen strömung innerhalb der spd
war scholz für die stasi nicht ein
gleichgesinnter wieso bespitzelte sie
ihn also warum die stasi bespitzelt hat
das ist nicht unbedingt immer von logik
geleitet die wollten halt alles wissen
und wenn jetzt jemand sagen wir mal sehr
links gewesen ist dann gab es die rein
theoretische möglichkeit dass man den ja
vielleicht auch mal irgendwann für sich
gewinnen konnte es gibt aber keinerlei
anzeichen darauf dass das bei olaf
scholz der fall war und was in der ddr
propaganda nicht deutlich wird bei den
treffen setzte sich scholz mit grenz und
co an einen tisch auch für westdeutsche
interessen am vierten januar
1984 war olaf scholz mit einer
delegation der jusos in der ddr und
wurde dort von egon krenz empfangen der
war damals sed politbüromitglied später
wurde er der nachfolger von erich
honecker
damals ging es in erster linie um fragen
der abrüstung die friedensbewegung
war in ost und west ein großes thema und
es wurden auch zwei aktivistinnen der
ostdeutschen friedensbewegung kurz
vorher verhaftet das wurde auch bei egon
krenz von den jusos damals angesprochen
also brisante neue informationen
sprechen wir darüber mit dem ehemaligen
direktor der stasi-gedenkstätte
berlin-hohenschönhausen hubertus knabe
hallo herr knabe
ich glaube die akte scholz zeigt dass
die stasi informationen über ihn
gesammelt hat warum hat sie das getan
die stasi hatte ja eine doppelfunktion
die hat die eigenen bürger überwacht
haben auch spionage betrieben und war in
der bundesrepublik der alten
bundesrepublik agentennetz vorhanden
auch innerhalb der spd und da sind
natürlich auch informationen immer den
vize chef der jungsozialisten angefallen
insbesondere von kurt wand im
endspiel den mann aus hamburg
hingerichtet aber dann vielleicht keine
missverständnisse aufkommen zu lassen es
ist keine bespitzelung in dem sinne
gewesen dass ein operativ auf vorgang
angelegt worden ist wie zu
bürgerrechtler in der ddr irgendwie
auszuforschen und letztlich außer
gefecht zu setzen im gegenteil wahr wenn
man das so sagen dass ein freund der die
hier
eher knabe warum brauchte der osten gute
beziehung in den westen und gerade das
in den 80er jahren
ja so würde ich das gar nicht
formulieren gute beziehung mit in den
westen ging ja damals darum in die nato
zu schwächen die ja damals als reaktion
auf neue mittelstreckenraketen und in
der sowjetunion ein beschluss gefasst
hatte auf solche ausgeben aufzustellen
und der anleger hat man versucht
anzugehen das zu verhindern und die
stationierung zu verhindern
und da spielt und die friedensbewegung
und vor allem auch die jungsozialisten
ändert sich diese heute weil die bis
1982 in die regierungspartei hinein
wirkt und es damals sich 82 war helmut
schmidt bundeskanzler und jungen
sozialisten waren quasi teil der
regierungspartei und trotzdem direkt auf
ein wirken und haben wir auch wenn es am
ende geschafft ist wie die dagegen die
nachrüstung einen beschluss zu fassen
sind helmut schmidt auch abgewählt
worden ist
vielen dank für die anordnung der knabe